I see myself with these speakers it's
like I'm starting a strip routine oh
maybe I am I good afternoon everyone
it's a real pleasure to be here I was
told by Tina & Co that I should talk
about past experiences which might
convey some lessons and I had to think
really hard about what I might talk
about which could actually have an
impact on a group of really smart people
like this and it turns out the best
lessons I have have actually been the
hardest ones to follow so I'm going to
talk about those at the beginning and
then I'm gonna disguise them a bit and
talk about them at the end as well the
topics I'm going to talk about will
firstly be being a bit irreverent not
just towards others but also towards
yourself because you and life are just
better that way makes you much better
entrepreneur second thing I'll talk
about is how once you've given yourself
that space you go about choosing a
problem that's really worthy of you and
several years of your life third thing
I'm gonna say some I'm gonna give some
thoughts on fundraising which I hope
will be helpful and then the last topic
I'm going to talk about how they catch
monkeys in central Africa so under the
first topic we are surrounded by so many
bright people at Stanford and in Silicon
Valley there are so many successful
people you know some of them by luck
some of them by hard work and
achievement but there's the subculture
that's emerged of reverence especially
at the business school no normative
judgments implied people want to be
associated with these folks who've done
so well and you want
to have them respect you and you want to
be up on a pedestal like they are and
I'm not saying be disrespectful
obviously you don't to be disrespectful
the the people around here I think
really do command respect but you want
to be a little bit irreverent because
it's going to help you make better
decisions it's going to give you that
sort of freedom from your own ego be a
little bit irreverent towards yourself
people are going to respect you more and
life is just going to be a lot happier
when I came to Stanford as an undergrad
I had won the National Science Olympiad
in South Africa which is this
competition that all the science
students take and it was kind of a big
deal
and I was good but I wasn't that good
and I was really lucky and I arrived at
Stanford studying electrical engineering
in physics I don't know where my parents
were I don't know where my academic
adviser was if my academic advisors
watching this I don't know where you
were and I had to be on a pedestal I
competed with everyone and I worked all
the time and lucky I had a couple of
friends who took me out from time to
time I don't know what they saw in me at
that stage but I to this day have never
had anyone outside of Stanford
University look at my transcript I've
never had a job interview
and after all of this work and all of
this competing it added so little to my
quality of life all it did is make me
want to be something for other people
and how they would see me and you should
really spend your time trying to work
out the things that you want to do for
the sake of doing them because they make
you feel good not because you want to
pay anything for anyone because it's
very hard to find your way back after
you've tried so long to be on a pedestal
and what actually happened to me is I
come out of my PhD my first company had
been sold and it was just a very
stressful time and I just come out of a
relationship and there's a lot of stuff
going on
and I had to work out my direction
vector in life and I had these two
friends this little furry Russian guy
called Ilya and his very cute Indian
girlfriend called Seema and they told me
that I had to go to the Pastner
meditation or somebody somebody seems to
approve of the concept Seema said to me
you know you've got such powers of
concentration but you're always
concentrating on the wrong thing so I we
just we're just warming up so I thought
you know I'm gonna give this her well
and I went to this Vipassana retreat
where you were in complete silence for
12 days meditating 9 hours a day and it
was horrific and you sit there with all
of this churning in your head and for
the there's the pain of your body
because you're meditating so many hours
in in in silence and stillness and
there's this furious rage I mean for the
first couple of days you're afraid
you're gonna die and for the next couple
of days you're afraid you won't and the
whole time there's this guru a really
impressive man SN Goenka and he actually
passed away on Sunday which is why he's
on my mind and he's saying to you the
whole time the char in this fury oh no
your brain is a chattering monkey Annie
Annie Annie
which means changing changing changing
and after six days or so I actually had
a breakthrough I was able to look at all
of these physical sensations and all of
this
from a place that was inside of me but
it wasn't inside my thoughts it was me
but I could just watch the sensations
and separate myself from my ego and you
realize that your brain is a completely
dysfunctional organ it has completely
lost the plot you are worrying about
what people are saying about you and
what they're thinking and whether you're
on your own schedule and what you've
achieved and what you're going to
achieve and it's all just dust in the
cosmos
all of these transient things and that's
a really powerful moment that I had and
I still try to meditate for an hour
every morning many years later but this
just makes me so much more likeable if
you think I'm not likeable now you
should see me when I haven't meditated
it just makes me a very different person
and it has application to so many things
in the path of an entrepreneur so I'm
going to talk about some of those things
that separation from your ego and a
certain irreverence help with one is
choosing classes you know you want to
come here and you want to be really good
you want to be respected you want to
take the hard classes and you want to be
on a pedestal the classes that made a
big impact for me or the classes around
the 200 level some 100 level classes
very few 300 level classes the
professor's I mean these are brilliant
guys but they are so enamored with their
work and they have such depth in their
particular class at sort of the late 200
300 level series that they are convinced
that you will not do anything useful
unless you do this class and the more
specific the class is the less useful
it's gonna be to you because once you've
chosen a problem that's really the
problem that you want to work on and
solve in life or in a portion of life
you're gonna have to learn the things
that you need to learn to solve that
problem you're never going to take
enough detail in a class that it's going
to give you the tools to solve the
problem that's the right problem for you
to work on
so be a little bit of reverent nobody
knows what you should take and what
you're good at and what you want to do
better than you do the same thing
applies for company ideas you know
they're the world's best companies I
would say have come out of Stanford but
very often professors academics in
general have a slightly distorted idea
of what it takes to bring a concept out
of the lab and actually have it be
impactful in the real world and this is
a mistake that I made you know I was a
consulting professor in aero-astro for
eight years and I learned that it took a
long time to get things into the real
world and there were a bunch of
considerations that one doesn't get to
in the academic setting it also applies
its level of irreverence applies to the
people that you want to put on your
board or the people that you want to get
as investors it's obviously great to
have big names associated with your
project and that can help you raise
money and people will take you seriously
but be really careful of the big
swinging Silicon Valley cojones who walk
around and they just kind of shoot from
the hip and you know they they patent
match and they give you quick advice
based on not really thinking about your
problem they'll do more harm than good
they can open doors but really you can
open doors yourself opening doors is not
the hard part when you got a really big
name they'll open doors that are
actually distractions because the doors
will open because they've got such a big
name and you a year later you realize
there wasn't really a viable business
there so you got to just look for those
people that can really respect you and
understand the particular challenges
that you're facing and work with you one
of the greatest directors I could ask I
I ever had as a director was Paul Baron
and I think he had the highest ratio of
achievement to humility that I've ever
encountered
and that's because he invented the
internet so he was a Polish engineer and
his father was a cobbler in Poland and
he always used to give these pieces of
advice in board meetings you know when
we were struggling about whether we
should show a demo
working through the details he'd say
things like well you know are these
engineers bright and we'd say well you
know they're kind of body's like are
they creative and like yeah you know the
guys that we're talking to at this big
company I don't really know and he'd say
cuz my father always used to say never
show a fool half-finished work and you
know and everyone be like mmm
oh that's really profound and it came
from you know his father who was a
cobbler in Poland he was just a really
wise guy and he worked on the first
computer systems the ENIAC and he
noticed that the thing kept breaking
because of bugs literally bugs that were
in the valves and he started to think
well how do we make a communication
system that's more robust than the sum
of its individual parts and he came up
with his concept that you could take a
message could split it up into its
constituent pieces and you could send it
into a network where each node would
make a decision about what the next
optimal trajectory for that message
should be that packet and at the end the
packets would be reassembled and that
was packet searching and he invented
this at the RAND Corporation and not
only did he invent it he wrote papers in
the 1960s for AT&T and the Department of
Defense about what the world of packet
switching would look like and he
described so much of what we do today on
the Internet really an amazing guy and I
had started my second company and I had
a group of board members and I was so
proud to have them be board members and
my mother was visiting from South Africa
and she is the most irreverent person
you've ever met in your life so I
thought she needed to meet these guys
because I was just wanting it wanting to
expose you know things that were
important in my life in California so we
sit down to lunch and I introduce these
various names and they're all on the
National Academy of Engineers you know
really big-name guys and then I
introduced Paul and I say to my mother
you know this is Paul Baran and he
invented packet switching which is the
architecture of the Internet and he
received the award from the FCC as the
father of the Internet and you say this
to people in Silicon Valley and they
start to shake and they drop on their
knees and they look at the guy my mom
said
why can't they make it work I've spent a
week calling my ISP in South Africa and
they keep telling me that it's going to
work and they keep telling me it's
reliable and they just can't seem to
make it work reliably and every day I
get the same story and it just doesn't
do what they're supposed to it what they
say it's supposed to do and everyone's
talking Internet mint in it why can't
they just make it work and Paul looked
at her I was hiding under the table you
know and Paul looked at Ernie said well
dr. Rabinowitz we're still working out a
few kinks and this is the nature of the
guy you know this is the kind of person
that you want to be associated with not
a big ego really thoughtful really
bright and really willing to work with
you and work through your challenges and
that ability to step away from wanting
to be on a pedestal is also really
relevant to the team that you hire in
your company one of the things is when
you start a company and it looks
interesting and it's going well people
are interested to get involved and it's
such a true it's so good for the ego
because you know everyone wants to be
involved with you and you want to build
this team don't do it it's not the
glamorous way but keep it tight make
your team when you start really small
and really bright and really focused
it's gonna end up being much better for
you as an entrepreneur and you're
probably going to end up starting a much
better company that way
same things VCS will often say to you
you need to spend more money spend and
the glamorous thing to do is to get a
nice office and spend and you know
really pursue when you are ready to
spend money in a company when there's
real need to spend money you will feel
it in every cell in your body you won't
be able to keep your foot off the
accelerator if you're spending money
just because it looks kind of good and
people are telling you to spend money
chances are you're spending money on the
wrong things or wastefully and it's not
going to be good for you financially in
the long term same thing applies to the
people that you bring onto the team you
know you want these people to not be
sort of glamour see because who want to
be on a pedestal you want these folks to
be tenacious the kind of people who will
stop at nothing
the kind of people who understand that
the Churchill quote where he says if
you're going through hell keep going
it's this beautiful notion that you just
there is always a path through there is
always a way and as an engineer I think
one learns over time there is always a
way there's a way around there's a way
through there's a different direction
you just need to have a team that will
stick with you to find it and not
wanting to be glamorous and on a
pedestal because those will be the first
people who will leave the company ok so
those are all the topics of you know
being slightly irreverent towards
yourself and others once you've given
yourself some space to really think
about the problem that you want to solve
the the message that the main message I
have learnt is to then focus on a
problem that is really worthy of you
worthy of you for several years because
these things always take longer and
consume more of your life and not to
focus on a technology that you want to
apply and that's also about irreverence
and letting go of your ego because
you've come out of Stanford a lot of
your PhDs or postdocs you've been
published and you are respected in your
field and you know so much about it and
very often it's just difficult to pry
that technology that particular know-how
out of a person's hand so they actually
focus on a problem that the market needs
to be solved it's very hard you gotta
let go of your ego and look at the
market and the problems in the world and
say what do I really want to work on and
learn what I need to learn to solve that
problem and there are always problems to
solve everywhere you look there's
problems and as technology becomes more
advanced society evolves around it and
there are new problems and that process
of refinement of the problem is has no
limits I have a personal bias on
problems that I think are important over
the next ten years because the best
companies so far out of Silicon Valley
have been the IT companies you know
they've certainly been the biggest
companies but if you look at the life we
lead today if communication networks get
much faster and we get much more
processor
power and we're able to render all
images in 3d
holographically and we find new ways of
making things go being on the internet
and making things go being on your
friends social network pages I just
don't think it's really going to change
the quality of life so much but when you
look at life when you look at the
problems of biology and health your
physical health mental health the
problems of Aging there are so many
challenges out there that are really
worth solving and are gonna be solved
you know when you look at that world
that it's like that Shakespeare quote
where he says it's Edgar in King Lear
where he says world world Oh world but
that thy strange mutations make us hate
thee life would not yield to age and
there's so much out there that requires
intellect to be solved my background was
information systems signal processing
physics and then I was in the Aero Astra
Department just as a consulting person
for eight years and the companies that
I'd started initially were in the IT
space in an Internet company then a
communications company and I'd invested
in a lot of IT areas and then my sister
had a child that was born with Down
syndrome and I spent six days while you
know everyone was sleepless just flying
around the country speaking to experts
trying to understand what could be done
and after six days the child died and
was just a horrific thing for a family
to go through and I couldn't believe it
I couldn't understand how in the 21st
century they could not know that a child
had Down syndrome until it was born and
once I got into it I learned the
limitations of the testing was
unbelievable either you could do these
hormone tests which missed about one in
six cases of Down syndrome and had very
limited coverage of all the other things
that can go wrong during a pregnancy or
you could do these invasive tests late
the pregnancy like an amniocentesis
where they take a needle and they stick
it in the woman's belly and they pull
fluid out of the uterus and they look at
the the cells and this has a chance of
miscarriage and can cause harm to the
fetus and it this was crazy so I started
to work on all sorts of problems we
could take signal processing and
optimization and apply it to challenges
in genetics and very soon we focused on
the problem of single cells and the
reason why single cells were so
important well there are many
applications but one of the applications
was in vitro fertilization because
that's a unique intervention in medicine
you've got ten embryos that have
fertilized in an IVF lab and the one or
two embryos that you choose to transfer
have direct impact on the outcome namely
the health of the born child and so if
you've got a family history of cystic
fibrosis so you've got a broker one
mutation that causes breast cancer or
you just are concerned about the
chromosomal structure of the embryos
because you want a high probability of
implantation about 80 percent of embryos
in an IVF cycle have a chromosomal
problem
you can take a single cell from the
embryo and you can analyze it to look at
the DNA but the challenge is if you look
at a single cell every molecule every
position on the chromosomes that you're
looking at is just one molecule so you
can't make that measurement reliably you
get a ton of allele dropouts where
there's a molecule there that you can't
see or you think molecules there that
aren't so we came up with this approach
where you would measure hundreds of
thousands of positions along the
chromosomes from that single cell and
that measurement was really noisy but
you'd also measure the genetic sample
from the parents and you would take the
data from the human genome project like
the hapmap database which tells you
where chromosomes cross over when the
parents are forming the sperm and the
egg that become the embryo and from that
very noisy measurement of the single
cell combined with that prior
information we could work out where the
crossovers happened in the parent
chromosomes to make the gametes that
became the embryo and if you
can work out whether those crossovers
happen you could reconstruct the DNA of
the embryo in silica so we can look at a
single cell and we can look at all sorts
of things and we do this for hundreds of
IVF centers around the country around
the world now actually and there's
amazing things that we can solve I mean
you have couples who have a born child
who's got a disease and they need cord
blood from another child to see if they
can help the born child now that cord
blood comes from the center and we will
take a single cell we can analyze that
single cell for six genes on the
histocompatibility complex to make sure
that it's compatible and we will look at
multiple disease linked loci to make
sure that the embryo doesn't carry that
disease susceptibility and we will
simultaneously look at all 24
chromosomes for insertions deletions
translocations inversions and 24
chromosome copy number and they will
select embryos based on that and my god
can this make a difference to people's
lives and we've got a lot of ethical
decisions we have to make with this
technology because we get a lot of crazy
requests I mean we are focused on
helping with severe disease or
phenotypes that are very high penetrance
in other words if you've got the genes
you're very likely to express the
disease but you know the other day we
got a call so a while ago actually to
our counselor and the caller said I use
a testing for my embryo with natera and
my mother is very beautiful Ukrainian
woman in my husband's mother is not
beautiful I don't want a child to look
like husband's mother if if look like
husband so she said you know you know
she wanted the child to have you know
blue eyes so the counselor said you know
yes we can do this we actually do know
the genes for blue eyes but we just
don't test for that it's like you don't
tell me what tests I get either I get
the child look like my grandmother if I
have a child look like the grand of like
husband mother I don't want child
and we had to deal with this woman who
was not prepared to pay for the test
unless we tested the things that she
wanted and obviously we wouldn't but
there are some real ethical questions
here that we have to grapple with every
day and it's a really challenging
problem those ethical questions have
become more and more challenging as our
tests have actually moved into higher
and higher volume markets so we offered
a test in a series of pregnancy and
reproduction related issues and the
really big test that you know has
probably so far the biggest test that
natera is offered that many of you might
have heard of is the panorama test where
at nine weeks into pregnancy instead of
having to do an invasive procedure much
later in the pregnancy or relying on
your screening tests which are very
limited sensitivity and specificity we
can just do a blood draw from a needle
stick in the mother's arm
regular blood draw that has no risk to
the fetus at all and from the tiny
traces of fetal DNA in the mother's
blood we can determine if there are
chromosomal problems in the fetus and
it's really cool how this technology
works we are using maximum likelihood
Bayesian estimation which is an
optimization signal processing concept
that's well understood in the
engineering side it's not so well
understood in the biology world the way
it works is you measure thousands of
positions on the chromosomes called
snips single nucleotide polymorphisms
these are positions where we have
genetic differences so I might have an A
you might have a C or a T or a G and
from that measurement of 20,000 snips we
construct a whole series of hypotheses
of what came from the parents to make
the DNA of the child so at a high level
that I get two chromosomes from the mom
one chromosome from the dad at a
particular chromosome like 21 which
would cause Down syndrome that would be
a trisomy 21 or did I get one chromosome
from each parent which would be normal
and within those very broad hypotheses
of what came from the parents we look at
literally trillions of sub hypotheses
describing where the crossovers happened
to make each of the chromosomes that
went into the kid and you calculate the
probability of each of those hypotheses
given what you have measured in the
plasma from the blood roll which is a
very noisy measurement and also given
what you know from the mother's DNA that
you get from the white blood cells in
that blood draw and also what you know
from the human genome project and so you
do this maximum likelihood estimation
technique and typically one of those
hypotheses will stand up above the
others with 99.99% probability and
that's your diagnostic call but if you
don't have a really high probability
call which is basically your confidence
you don't make a guess you say look do
another blood draw and we'll get a
really reliable result and the data on
this test is absolutely staggering you
know we've done a series of trials the
latest data that I have from one of our
trials was about 1,300 samples and
looking at Down syndrome and trisomy 13
and 18 which are the most common and
severe whole chromosome problems that
you can have during a pregnancy we had a
hundred percent sensitivity and 99.9
percent specificity it's just really
impressive data and it's not obvious
it's not a hundred percent because
biology is just not that simple but the
performance of this test is quite
incredible and it's changing the way
people manage pregnancies all over the
world and not only are we just looking
at whole chromosome problems we are
starting to look at all sorts of sub
chromosomal issues because we found that
these lead to kids being born they don't
show up as abnormal in ultrasound but
these sub chromosomal insertions and
deletions have children born who have
mental retardation developmental delays
organ abnormalities and these kinds of
challenges when I started in this field
there was this canonical wisdom that
about 3% of pregnancies were abnormal
and we didn't really know the genetic
causes but we thought most of them were
genetic now we're actually at a point
where we can explain roughly the
majority of those abnormalities on a
genetic basis and the question is what
do we actually test for during the
pregnancy when we put
20 of the top maternal fetal medicine
specialists in a room and the top guys
in the country really bright people none
of them can actually agree on what are
the things that should actually be
tested for during a pregnancy you know
that definition of what's abnormal and
you know severe enough is a totally
loose definition so it presents us with
real challenges and this has been an
experience for me which has been
ethically really interesting technically
really interesting and it was a great
problem for me to choose I was very
lucky in some ways that I encountered
that personal tragedy and I'm going to
just say a couple other things about the
problems that one should choose leading
on from that one aspect is when you
choose your problem and you are looking
for your solution make sure that you
pick a solution which is in your own
control manage your own destiny as much
as possible when we came up with this
technology can I walk by the way track
me that's cool okay technology when I
when we were looking at how to build a
business around this technology people
said well you want to license the
technology because you don't build a lab
you're not going to be able to scale and
we decided actually that it made sense
for us to raise a little bit more money
and build our own lab and do the trials
ourselves and start offering these tests
out of our own clear lab and was a
little bit longer you know now we've got
this lab I don't know if you guys see it
in San Carlos there's the the old
necktie building is now then a terrible
ding with the embryo on the top of the
building it's kind of this embryo flower
looks really cool and we've got 300
people in that lab who are doing the
tests ourselves but having done this
ourselves having developed these tests
and offered these tests ourselves we now
have partnerships with all the top labs
in every continent around the world in
the United States the panorama test is
being distributed by quest which is the
biggest lab in the world and about ten
other key labs in the US we got the
biggest lab in South
America biggest lab in Canada biggest
lab in Western Europe top genetics lab
in China Korea Japan Russia Africa in
Johannesburg my hometown so and there's
about 40 labs 45 labs around the world
now who are distributing the tests and
now we can use that pipeline that
infrastructure that we've set up with
these labs to give them our molecular
protocol they can run the samples
themselves and we can run the
informatics in the cloud and there's a
whole series of things that are going to
go down the pipeline a whole series of
new and different tests that we're going
to be working on related to personalized
medicine but we had to get to that point
and to get to that point it was really
valuable that we were able to offer the
tests ourselves you can spend years
trying to convince some important person
in some big company that they've got to
change their plans and take you
seriously and it's really hard to do
that unless you really have the control
to do it yourselves so that's the one
thing try to keep destiny in your own
hands as much as possible the other
thing is make sure that you choose a
test that's in a hot and growing market
it really makes life so much easier when
you've got something which the market
really wants and sometimes it's very
difficult for you to work out what that
is it's not your expertise so one of the
things that's great about Silicon Valley
is there are lots of people around here
who have that expertise and this is
bringing me to my third topic which is
thoughts on fundraising a lot of people
will say you know don't take a ton of
venture money upfront or any venture
money do it with friends and family
keep it tight until you've increased
your valuation I actually have seen very
different evidence I would say raise
institutional money as fast as you can
and then spend as little of it as
possible and the reason for that is
twofold firstly you know VCS can be very
bright and they can be very dumb
I would say an equal split but it's not
quite and I'm not going to say we're in
split lives but you know if you can't
convince one institutional investor that
you have something which is suited for
the market you've got the wrong plan and
Silicon Valley has two great things it's
got a lot of capital a lot of investors
and it's also got these folks whose job
it is to work out what the market needs
and what can work in the market and
that's incredibly helpful for you as an
entrepreneur because it's often your
blind spot especially when you come out
of Stanford so raise money not that
Stanford is used to having blind spots
most universities all universities have
way bigger blind spots I would say then
Stanford but coming out of an academic
environment it's difficult to work out
what really connects to the market so
convince somebody at an institutional
level to put money into a project it if
you can't do that keep working on what
the plan should be the other reason it
makes a lot of sense I think is you will
end up getting less diluted usually
there are a few cases where everything
goes so beautifully that you know you
raise money from institutional's at a
much higher valuation than what your
angels or your friends and family had
but that's usually not the case if it's
a good problem it usually costs more and
takes longer and if you're still in the
process of trying to get to the key
milestones and then you need to raise
institutional money very likely they're
going to pay what they would have paid
if you've gone to them the first time
your angels get diluted you get diluted
and it usually is a much less optimal
outcome for the entrepreneur so I would
say go to the end go to the investors as
early as you can and when you go to the
investors you've got to choose if you
have the choice choose venture
capitalists who you like and respect and
more than anything trust because there
will come a time however you set it up
there will come a time when your fate is
largely at least intertwined possibly
controlled by them and there are two
philosophies roughly two philosophies in
venture capital you got the you know big
swingin cojones who invest in
company and very often they'll gut the
company of the founders and they free up
a lot of common stock and then they put
in their own management team and that
can be a very good decision for them to
make and they've been some big companies
both just that way and then you've got
venture capital group's who rarely have
a philosophy of partnering with the
founder and that's part of their credo
if you look at a firm like Sequoia
Capital for example I think it's about
80% of the companies that IPO or sell
have a liquidity event that our Sequoia
companies still have the original
founders running the show and that's
because they look for people that they
really want to partner with and really
want to work with for the long haul and
if you can get money from a fund like
that even if it's at a slightly lower
valuation I would really say take it
it's gonna make a difference when you
meet with an investor VC it's quite
amazing I think the lesson I've learned
there is what you see is what you get
you you're always wondering well what
are they going to be like and doing
reference tricks just use your eyes and
ears when you go into the meeting and
the guy sitting there Ernie's on his
cell phone and then he's kind of got all
these opinions and pattern matching that
are not really relevant to your problem
and telling you what you should do but
he hasn't really thought it through and
he's not really giving at the time I
guarantee you however big that person's
name you're gonna have problems unless
you are really lucky so what you see is
what you get just look for a person
who's listening to you working the
problem thinking about the problem and
gives you that level of respect so all
right those are the easy things those
are the decisions Oh actually there's
one more thing I wanted to mention I
think it's a gem maybe it'll help maybe
it won't but listen up there's a new
paradigm in liquidity over the last
couple of years where you don't have to
sell your company or go public in order
to have liquidity as a founder because
there's all these organizations that are
enabling secondary sales in the market
for investors who want to get involved
in the company but are not part of the
key team and as a founder often that you
know IPO is a schlep and it's a
distraction so you might decide to delay
the IPO or things might just take longer
in the company
and you have things that you want to do
you want to build a house you've got
family commitments and obligations when
you start your company it's a really
good idea to put in a little bit of your
own money not a lot because that's gonna
make you irrational but put a little bit
of your own money to get preferred stock
and the reason why preferred stock is so
valuable is if you want to sell it a few
years down the road in the secondary
transaction you can sell that preferred
stock at a high valuation without
messing up the valuation of your options
they don't ruin your 409a valuation for
the sec because you've got particular
rights and voting privileges associated
with that preferred stock and that will
give you the flexibility to sell your
stock earlier it can make a really big
difference when you get your initial VCS
involved you need to talk to them about
this and the good funds who partner with
the entrepreneurs will understand that
you just have commitments in life that
you want to fulfill you know at some
point down the road so okay those are
the easy decisions because those are the
decisions that are hopefully mostly in
your control now I want to talk about
how one makes decisions when the
underlying variable is just not in your
control at all when I was coming out of
my PhD my first company had been sold it
was an Internet company we were just
lucky it was just the right thing at the
right time and the company was sold at
$30 per share and by the time I could
say hey don't knock inflation so $30 per
share and not that I had much control
over that but by the time I could sell
my stock it was worth 16 and I thought
well you know I'm not gonna sell it 16
it's worth 30 and then the stock was
worth 10 and I sold a little bit of 10
but I thought well that's just
irrational I'm not gonna sell a lot of
10 because if I didn't sell it 16 why
would I sell a 10 does anyone know how
they catch monkeys in central Africa
nobody so what they do is they hollow
out a log and they put these really
yummy berries in the log and there's a
hole that the monkey puts his hand
through to get the berries and the
monkey is so empty
to have the berries that it won't let go
of them although with its first closed
it can't get its hand out of the hole
and even when the hunters come out to
grab the monkey it still will not let go
of the berries it's just too psyched and
you look at this and you think I mean
actually you think poor little monkey
but you look at the see like you stupid
monkey let go of the berries so this
happened just before the first bubble
burst and it's right and I lost pretty
much everything and at the time I was
painful in retrospect it wasn't such a
big deal there was a lot of money
at the time but it wasn't such a big
deal and actually it was a really good
thing for me that this happened a really
good thing it made me work on better
problems it made me a better person
but the lesson that I came out of this
with is 50% half it's an incredibly
powerful number if you're thinking of
selling sell half if you're wondering
whether to buy buy half if you're in a
negotiation and you want to make an
offer to the other side but you don't
know how they're going to react offer
half
whatever you do however it turns out
it's not in your control directly you're
going to be half right and half wrong
and you're not going to have regrets and
managing your own emotions as an
entrepreneur is probably the most
important thing and it doesn't just
apply to these decisions try to find the
balance in everything really everything
even find the balance in irreverence
because there's some incredible things
in the world and at Stanford to treat
with reference but if you can look at
things that happen and especially the
bad things and realize that there is a
good side to every bad thing that
happens sometimes it's manifest right
away sometimes it takes a long time to
manifest but if you can treat every
event with that sense of balance and let
yourself be free enough from your ego to
wait for the good side to emerge and to
look for the good side
you've probably achieved the most
important thing that you can achieve as
an entrepreneur and that's it
now
thank you so much for these inspiring
words so now we're going to open it up
for questions and I'm gonna ask you the
first one while everyone else is getting
their their thinking together and their
questions together so this is really
inspiring and clearly you've
accomplished a lot one of the biggest
challenges that you're facing now in
this company biggest challenges it's
like an interview question I want to say
we all work too hard I think the biggest
challenge is on the on the ethical side
making sure that just because we can do
something we don't necessarily do it and
it's the right thing to do before we do
it and that's the one part of the
business that actually doesn't scale I
think is is the genetic counseling so we
got a whole team of genetic counselors
at the company and when we have an
abnormal result they will get on the
phone with a doctor and sometimes the
patient as well and talk through the
details and it's quite amazing that the
doctors who are offering these tests are
often way behind the curve and they
don't know all of the complexity of the
testing and all the things that you can
and can't say from a test so we try to
err on the side of excessive information
and excessive caution on our reports we
will give much more information than the
tip then a doctors typically want to
deal with because they got very limited
time per patient and it can actually
confuse the patients to get so much
information so we've got to spend a lot
of time with the genetic counselors and
as we want to give more information for
example to look at deletions and
duplications in the sub chromosomal
structure this becomes more of a
challenge so it's not like that you can
really do about it except you know you
want to work closely with medical
geneticists you want to have a lot of
education of the doctors who are
offering your tests you want to you know
make sure that there is you know a lot
of bioethics engagement and and senior
doctor engagement and the test that one
offers and you want to spend a lot of
time in genetic counselors to make sure
that the information that we provide is
actually actionable and explained to the
doctors and the patients in the right
way
it
so it's a very interesting challenge but
it's a very real challenge great another
question yes you mentioned that nine
weeks into a pregnancy you guys have a
test for whether there's an abnormality
in a baby say the mother finds out there
is an abnormality what is the mother
expected due at that point and what are
your guys results on like the statistics
of what mothers or parents do decide
after finding out errors about her mouth
great question that's a wonderful
question the question is we can do this
test at nine weeks and sometimes people
actually do it later than nine weeks
that determines if there's an
abnormality in the fetus but what do
people actually do when they get that
information and what are the statistics
of what next steps people usually take
great question I've had personal
experience with this which I'm not going
to go into here but I'll tell you there
is never a right answer in those
situations what you really care about is
giving the information to the parents
and the doctors as early in the
pregnancy as possible and what you
previously had is people would get the
information often after the screening
tests you know in the second trimester
or after an annual synthesis and then if
they chose to terminate the pregnancy
it's horrific it's a you know it can be
a two day procedure and it's really a
terrible thing for people to go through
so you want to give them the information
as early as you can and one of the key
timings that you care about is if you
get it through the screening test you
want to do a confirmatory invasive
procedure like a CVS and you can do that
CVS that chorionic villus sampling is an
invasive procedure you can do that 11 to
13 weeks into the pregnancy and so you
want to get a really reliable result
that early in the pregnancy so that if
they do choose to do a CVS and if they
do choose to terminate a pregnancy they
can do it really early it makes a really
big difference to what the couple goes
through now on the other hand there are
certain things that we test for like
Klinefelter syndrome which you actually
have interventions during the pregnancy
and some of the other things that we
test for where
although you don't have an intervention
during the pregnancy you can plan
exactly what you're gonna do as soon as
the baby is born and the baby will be
born in the right Hospital and then more
than anything it's a question of the
parents just preparing it makes a huge
difference if you just know early in the
pregnancy rather than be shocked in the
middle of the pregnancy or late in the
second trimester
it really does make a huge difference
that people have that information and
can think about it and make you know
considered plans in terms of what people
choose to do it's quite amazing it
really you know as you might expect it's
very different on the coasts of America
the blue states versus the red states in
the blue states more than 80 percent of
people will typically terminate a
pregnancy for Down syndrome for example
in the red states more than 80 percent
of people won't terminate a pregnancy
for Down syndrome and you know Down
syndrome is the most common one so it's
it's really dependent on the particular
culture and mindset that people have and
there are no right answers it's such a
when you you know I don't want to make
this too personal but having just seen
what people go through when they get
that news it doesn't matter what people
have said they were going to do in their
discussions what their plans were so
often they are just lost and so what you
really want to do is give them all the
genetic counseling support and give them
as much information as you can as
reliably as you can as early as possible
when you get started you have no
customers no money no track record it's
bleak and you have your first customers
how do you make sure that you keep them
happy it really depends on the it really
depends on the field in which you're
working so I don't think I can really
give a catch-all but I think the first
answer is listen to them listen to your
customers and by listen I mean really
size them out for the things that they
like and also get them involved in the
design process because your prototype is
going to always be a prototype that
needs to be iterated and not going to be
the final version and if your customers
feel that they are part of that process
and they take a certain ownership that
can really lock them in emotionally in
terms of you know other things that one
can do I guess sales and marketing is a
big deal
marketing is everything this is a room
mostly of Engineers the way some people
dress I think they're probably marketing
people but for the engineers in the
audience marketing is everything and
good salespeople are worth their weight
in gold so you know you you want to have
a great engineering team and a great
technology but you also want to have a
really bright and really committed
marketing and sales team and getting
that message out can often be really
hard and you know often competing
against really big companies who have
much bigger sales and marketing budgets
so you need to have people who are
bright and tenacious and focused and get
the sales and marketing going early
change where you draw the line and how
do you as a company do with what we
don't change hormones so the question is
as our ability to offer different tests
that are looking at more and more
complex disease states and phenotypes
that may or may not be really you know
high penetrance you know very variables
of unknown clinical significance
variants of unknown clinical
significance how do we make a decision
on what to offer and what not to and I
assume you're looking for some sort of
mechanistic approach the we get patients
in the IVF context where we have time to
think about it you know sometimes people
will ask for certain things and we have
time to really make a considered
response for example the I'm you know I
don't want to get into examples because
you know I I don't know just we can
maybe talk about that afterwards but
sometimes couples will want certain
things on the embryos to be okay when
they've got a condition and we sometimes
have very hard decisions to make so the
first thing that you do is you spend a
lot of time with your medical
geneticists and your genetic counselors
and you've got to really understand what
the issue is and more often than not
we'll just say you know we'll we'll give
the the couple the freedom to choose but
if it's a serious disease that actually
in any way shortens we will only screen
for serious diseases if the couple wants
to allow for an embryo that has a
condition we try as much as possible to
let them make that decision
unless they are doing something
responsible and so it's really hard you
got to make these decisions case-by-case
even for a particular disease like
cystic fibrosis the different mutations
have very different penetrants so you've
really got to look at the particular
mutations and get a lot of advice from
your medical
geneticists in terms of what we do going
forward we have a whole advisory board
for panorama as an example we have a
whole advisory board of M FM's and
genetic experts who will come together
to recommend what the next thing should
be on the panel and we've just been
through this process actually and there
are certain there are certain deletions
for example where I don't want to say
exactly what they are because it's gonna
come out in a couple of months this
panel but there are certain deletions
where you know some doctors are just
banging the table and they say you know
I've seen patients like this and it's a
problem and you you cannot not tell
people about this and then there are
other doctors you know all senior guys
who are saying you you shouldn't tell a
couple about this because it's a
phenotype of variable penetrants and
what are they going to do during
pregnancy and you're going to worry them
from a genetic counseling perspective
it's it's just a real problem so we just
have to navigate this and do it with a
lot of care and a lot of time the thing
that we will try to avoid responding to
is when decisions are made because the
healthcare system in this country is so
challenged a lot of decisions get made
because the doctors just don't have time
and they say I just don't have genetic
counseling time to deal with the
complexities of this particular disease
when that happens we were almost just on
principle say no there is got to be a
way to get people informed and our
genetic counselors can carry a lot of
that load so I guess the answer is you
really got to follow the professional
societies and when you're doing
something that the head of the
professional societies you've got to get
you know the world the National experts
involved can you further elaborate on
how how we apply the concept of
irreverence to drink drugs
joking joking how do you apply your
irreverence you know I think I said most
of what I can say except for one thing
don't let any amount of stress or any
amount of schoolwork stop you making
really good friends and going out and
exploring the world with him the most
important thing for me has been just a
couple of people who pulled me out of a
little dark corner of the lab once a
week and took me out and these became
you know the friends that I made it as
an undergrad at Stanford have been you
know really like brothers and sisters to
me and they have changed my quality of
life more than anything that I studied
yeah so it's a balance I'm not saying be
irreverent Stanford's did a really
impressive place I mean obviously one is
very proud to be associated with place
like this but don't let other people
decide what's right for you you know
what's right for you better than anyone
else does and have that little bit of
irreverence so you can just think about
that for yourself and don't try to be on
a pedestal for them and while you're at
it try to find some time to do other
things like make really good friends
spend time with people here because
there will be really important people
later in life I think I'm sure this has
been a fascinating way to start the
quarter thank you join me in thanking
Matt
you